instead of appearing as a guest we had
thought maybe would have you know as a
guest Trump had a very special request
he said he wanted to direct an episode
of our show yeah yeah he wants to direct
call the camera shots the whole thing
well naturally he's the biggest story in
the news so I said yes Trump's in our
control room right now please welcome
our guest director tonight Donald Trump
thank you thank you
let's get to a candy food cameraman
damage whoo
hey sweetie you know one cute and I know
cute road okay Ned mr. Trump that's not
a judge Oh God would you like to be the
future edge mrs. Trent mr. trauma that's
not a property mr. Trump I have to ask
why did you stop campaigning for
president to come and direct our show
it's simple cue patriotic music slow
push in uncoding my fellow Americans
if I can take a show like Conan's
and make it great again imagine what I
can do for America thank you cut the
music cue applause
no don't applaud that mr. Trump what's
wrong with my show
seriously look around you Conan where
other chandeliers where's the shrimp
buffet let's bring some class to this
dump our God what the hell is that it is
a solid gold fountain filled with the
sweat of Ukrainian supermodels now let's
fix the mood crazy cut to that Andy
Griffith guy
what hey you let him put a Trump logo on
your head he gave me 50 bucks
oh okay now let's get rid of some of the
dead weight of your audience
loser loser slob
lightweight dummy pothead that's a
problem that's very insulting I don't
think your directing is working out
you're right if I wait a minute no you
know you can't fire me I don't work for
you I work for TBS it's not TB s anymore
it's Trump BS right no no no no it is
definitely time for you to go okay fine
keep your losses show but before I go
camera seven
you really are one cute broad let me
tell you keep us Q sexy music oh my god
what I begun president you could be the
first fourth lady
what do you swing by the control room
and I'll let you when you think is very
close to my hair without actually
physically touching no if you just once
you stop the hearts and music and please
go getting to have time today no we're
not having a rock time we have a great
show with Sir Patrick Stewart okay he's
good but I could have got you some real
top talent including will of the tape
meatloaf
Stephen boggling playing a key Billy Ray
Cyrus
Victoria Gotti then creep from that
family with all the care Dennis Rodman
and cootie and some of the blood mr.
Trump thank you appreciate if I wasn't
that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]